hey guys this is your final month in the
90-day weight-loss challenge to a new
you firstly congratulate yourself for
getting to this point losing weight is
not easy and you have achieved a great
deal so enjoy your success you deserve
the very best for all the effort hard
work and time you have put in do you fit
better in your clothes do you feel
better about yourself
are you more energized and upbeat well
let's start the third month by
reevaluating your goal weight do you
still have 15 pounds or more to lose if
so continue on your current workout and
meal plan and be sure to increase your
workout intensity every four weeks to
challenge your muscles and keep burning
fat you can also get my month 3 workout
plan from my websites or are you at your
final 5 to 10 pounds and you're kind of
struggling to lose the last few pounds
I'll be sharing with you 10 tips to
break through your plateau when you go
on a weight loss journey at one point or
another you will hit a plateau where the
skill just stop moving this usually
happens when you get closer to your goal
firstly it's important to understand
that as you start losing weight your
overall metabolism decreases because
your body has to burn fewer calories to
control a smaller you
therefore the heavier you are the more
you burn the lighter you are the less
you burn the safe weight loss ratio is
between 1 to 2 pounds per week but as
you get closer to your goal expect to
only lose between 1/2 to 1 pound per
week
hence it takes much longer for a smaller
you to lose the last 5 to 10 pounds in
comparison to when you initially started
at a much heavier weight before I share
my tips with you I want you to reassess
your ideal weight and be honest
ask yourself if the magic number is
really the right weight for you perhaps
you have lost fat and gained muscles so
your new toned body is much healthier
and have
with few extra pounds on for instance
when I started working out my goal was
to be 45 kilos because that was my
weight in high school as I started
training I realized that I will never be
45 kilos again because of the additional
muscles I have so now I'm between 48 to
50 kilos but I am much smaller in frame
in comparison to when I was 45 kilos
basically more lean muscles and less
body fat another factor to consider is
once you have achieved your magic number
will you be able to maintain
approximately the same workout and diet
pace for the rest of your life I want
you to start thinking about your
maintaining strategy now so set a
sustainable life goal where you will be
able to sustain your new weight for life
I'm sure you know somebody who has lost
a lot of weight but several months down
the road he or she has put on 10 pounds
or more or this might has even happened
to you this is because you have only
been aiming for your weight goal but you
have not been aiming for your life goal
hence once you achieve your weight goal
you tend to let go and that's when the
weight starts to creep back on so I'm
going to share with you 10 tips to lose
the last 5 to 10 pounds and this is also
applicable to those of you who is
looking to maintain your weight so let's
start by looking at your workouts the
first tip is to workout less but intense
no matter what workout you do if you
were to increase the intensity you won't
burn more fat and you will lose weight
quicker so do interval trainings instead
of steady paced cardio increase the
weights you're using do explosive
movements like jump squats reduce your
rest time to burn more fat and to burn
more calories intensity is more
important than your workout length
spending only 20 to 30 minutes of
intense workout and giving it your
maximum effort is far more effective
than an hour long of moderate jogging
not only where you burn more fat during
the short period of time you will also
be burning more after your workout which
is no
as the afterburn the more intensive
workout is the greater the afterburn
effect your body will burn fat more
efficiently between 24 to 48 hours after
an intense workout so increase your
intensity tip number two is to switch
your workouts when your body is
accustomed to doing the same workout for
the past three to four months it will
not be as effective anymore
so try something completely different
when you force your body to adapt new
movements you will start burning again
for instance if you are used to running
four times weekly and you have a very
good stamina that does not mean you will
have the same stamina if you were to
start swimming so try to run twice
weekly and swim twice weekly instead or
even join a yoga class Pilates class
cycling or try boxing which is something
I'm currently doing at the moment some
of you have mentioned that I look leaner
nowadays and that's just by mixing up my
workout by adding one kickboxing session
a week I have seen and feel the
difference myself switching your
workouts will not only boost your
metabolic rate it will make your routine
feel fresh again it's motivating and
it's especially important if you are at
a maintenance stage so try something
completely different the third tip is to
strength train at least twice a week as
I've mentioned earlier as your body gets
smaller your metabolism will slow it
down and that is why losing the last few
pounds is so difficult metabolic rate is
directly linked to the amount of muscles
you have in your body the more lean
muscles you have the higher your resting
metabolic rate will be if you want to
tone up strength training is the way
those who do a lot of cardio with our
strength training can be slim but not
toned strength training will give you a
firmer physique and it will help to give
you a better posture so aim to do your
strength training and you can mix it up
with your cardio which is what most of
my workout videos are a combination of
strength training and cardio so let's
move on to food and you
tuition the next tip is to cut 100 to
150 calories from your daily intake
reevaluate your food intake and see how
many calories do you currently consume
it's worth to recalculate how many
calories does your body need at your new
weight because the smaller you are the
less calories you will need you can use
my video here to calculate based on the
calculation we want to cut back on some
calories to lose the last 10 pounds you
don't have to make radical changes if
you are already increasing the intensity
of your workouts eating clean all you
need to do is to slash between 100 to
150 calories to see the difference
another tip that has been proven to work
is to alternate between high and low
calories day cycling your calories is
the process of eating more on certain
days and less on other days for instance
if you consume an average of 1,500
calories a day try consuming 1300
calories on one day and consume 1,700
calories on the next day as long as you
create a weekly deficit you should see
the pounds drop this concept is similar
to shopping your muscles by introducing
new workouts we want to shock your
metabolism by cycling your calories the
next tip is to reduce starchy carbs too
before and after your workout I am NOT
against carbs carb is needed as part of
a balanced diet but it has a very unique
effect on your home and insulin where it
causes your body to store more than you
burn hens are really simple and short to
method is to cut on your carbs until you
have achieved your goal which is also
known as the high protein your cups
diet eat lean protein and lots of
vegetables and every meal and limit your
carbs to only before and after your
workout for your muscles to recover and
rebuild on the contrary if you can't
seems to limit your cards to only before
and after your workout and you are
looking for something more sustainable
why not try to reduce you
meat consumption instead reducing meat
consumption has been proven to lighten
up the scale plant-based foods are
naturally much low in calories and
higher in fiber therefore it will keep
you satisfied without overeating try
replacing your meat with eggs tofu beans
or even fish fish is much low in
calories but packed full of good fat and
protein don't have to make drastic
changes try it out for maybe twice a
week or go vegetarian throughout the day
and have your meat for dinner if you are
not ready to give up your meat why not
make smarter choices so choose limit
cuts of meat and choose white meat like
chicken or turkey over red meat because
they are much higher in fat and choose a
healthier way to prepare them as well so
steamed boil or grill them instead of
frying them all these small changes will
make a huge difference tip number eight
is to rest and sleep most people think
that by training harder you will speed
up weight loss this is true if you were
to balance it out with resting if your
workout is constantly intense and your
diet is to streak you could over train
and eventually burn out your muscles
need rest to repair and grow when your
body is at rest it allows recovery
improves fat loss and helps to regulate
hunger if you train hard without resting
you are actually cutting your fat loss
rate by half lack of sleep also
increases appetite so if you are awake
for a longer period of time you will
feel hungry which will encourage you to
eat more eight to ten hours is what you
need per night for your body to maximize
fat loss if you think you might be
overtraining where you are both mentally
and physically tired one tip that I have
seen work is to stop any physical
activity for the next four to seven days
and then continue back on your regular
workout routine after that by allowing
your body and mind to fully rest for
four to seven days you may be surprised
to find the skill movie
again tip number nine is to stand and
walk when it comes to losing the last
ten pounds and eventually maintaining
your weight we should already start
adopting healthier habits effortlessly
small habits like standing more often or
get out and walk every day will help you
to burn an additional of 200 to 300
calories without even trying hard so
when you can walk to places choose to
walk up the stairs instead or do your
regular morning walks while intense
workouts tend to make us hungry walking
does not have the same effect so walking
is a really easy way to burn extra fat
without increasing our appetite the last
tip is to stop being obsessed and focus
on performance goal instead being
obsessed with this magic number will
lead to stress stress will cause your
body to hold on to precious fat so when
you're getting stressed out because the
skill isn't moving well guess what the
additional stress is actually hindering
the skill from moving so instead of
focusing on the magic number shift your
focus to fuel performance goal for
instance if you can't do any two
push-ups yet make that your goal to be
able to do three to five push-ups by the
end of the month if you have just joined
a dance class or a yoga class make it
your goal to master and perfect all the
moves and believe me when you achieve
your performance goal you will see the
skill move you will feel and look better
and more importantly you had fun doing
it instead of just getting stressed out
so start trusting that all the positive
changes you've made in your life are
going to work focus on enjoying the
process instead as you are getting
closer to your goal
remember fitness is for life it's not
just a magic number to achieve once you
have achieved it and then what mix
things up make your trainings fun and
your your meals having a much more
relaxed Fitness approach has helped me
to maintain my win and I am sure
we'll help you two for new fitness food
and motivational videos please like
share and subscribe to my youtube
channel and website do follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter to stay
connected with me thanks guys
you